Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
May 7th,
2018 what's going on?
How is ya?
How's it going?
How are you?
Is your hockey team still alive in the NHL playoffs?
While you know what?
Congratulations.
I hope you're happy because mine isn't.
Mine is not.
Mine is done for the Goddamn season.
I do want,
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Hit the trainer while doing the podcast.
Yeah.
Oh,
fucking consideration.
For the high level of quality of a program that's going on in here.
Why would you do that?
You come in here and you apologize to the incredible intellect of my listeners.
Sorry.
I,
yeah,
I just,
I hit friends.
Oh my God.
Mia,
can we sit down and talk about how you cut up that steak last night?
Oh,
oh.
Where are you running?
What do you run into?
We are.
Why would he does not listen to this?
You want to talk about one of one of the shady,
his moods ever moves.
Ever.
Come here.
Sit down.
Gorgeous.
We'll bring her in here.
They'll take some of the sting out of what I'm going to say to you.
So anyways,
so we go out,
you know,
a friend of ours in town and of course she wanted to meet our lovely,
beautiful,
absolutely charming.
Always in a great mood,
gorgeous daughter right now we love showing her off.
We love getting the compliments.
Oh my God.
I know right?
I did that.
You know I didn't,
I took a half court shot and God did the rest of the law.
Um,
anyways,
so we ended up going out to a steak house,
right.
Sydney.
I was like,
I don't want to stick but I'd like some steak.
Are you going to order a steak?
And it's like,
yes.
When in Rome.
Hi.
Did you just say hi to me?
You say hi to the listeners.
Qt.
So me as just like a,
you kind of get a steak.
I don't want to want a whole steak.
I wanted to get tuna tar,
tar and I wanted a crap.
The lump crab cake,
which is what you ordered.
Yes.
And I wanted a little bit as day cause I want to do a little surf and turf.
Yeah.
So what does all freckles to what is all freckles still?
He orders of course.
What do you order?
Oh,
Billy steak face.
I ordered the bone in Ribeye.
How the hell did that happen?
Sorry,
what just happened there?
Somehow I moved in.
The volume got turned down anyways,
I'll have to edit that part out.
So anyways,
all Billy stake face,
I order a bone in Ribeye.
So Cutie Pie here starts getting frustrated.
Nah,
starts making noise and I,
you know,
I don't want to be that guy.
It's a restaurant with a baby that's crying,
especially in a steakhouse steak house.
She have a lot of people,
they're in their second marriages.
People who you know,
didn't get married,
guys who are paying for a house that they're no longer allowed to go into.
You know,
there's a lot of that go there.
a lot of child support being paid,
you know,
by some of these people who had to rebuild it again.
So the led lady g of belly hanging out.
Look at your belly hanging out,
what are you doing?
So she was,
my daughter was getting frustrated,
so I just started,
I started walking around the restaurant and everything like that being the
amazing father that I am right running around,
she still short.
I got to like,
you know,
bend it that angle,
then it's like killing my back.
But I,
but I stuck it out.
I did it for you.
I did it for all those divorces in there.
Right.
All those people paying child support,
even though the women that women are starting to pay child support to.
Oh you haven't seen it,
you haven't read that.
And cosmo.
Cosmo,
yeah.
Yeah.
And they out there that complaining that which I love.
I love this whole equal pay cause you wait near,
you wait until enough women have to start paying child support and you watch
those divorce laws changed.
Um,
so anyways,
while I'm being the amazing father then than I am obviously,
this is my,
uh,
this is my version of the story.
Uh,
my stake arrives.
So Nia goes to cutoff her portion of the steak and basically what she does is
she cuts the thing like length wise,
right?
A lot like an inch away from the bone and she takes all the meat along the bone
and then gives me the rest of it.
And for those of you who aren't meat eaters,
all you vegetarians out there,
the most flavorful part of a bone in Ribeye,
the reason is,
is all along the bone.
And she took the best meat and I was so upset with her.
I told her that she needed to go to ancestry.com because that was some northern
white European shit.
What you just did there?
I
uh,
I,
yeah,
I took the yeah,
I did.
That's my favorite fight.
The bone.
All right guys.
Ever want to know?
If you want to know what it's like to be a husband and a father,
that's what it is.
She makes the baby.
She goes through all of that.
She goes through nine months of hell,
10 months a hell.
Actually that's the middle three.
That's like the summer vacation.
But whatever.
We'll say 10 months of hell and you know what?
And then as a guy,
you pay for it for the rest of the relationship.
She gets it all back with little f little shady cuts of bone in Ribeye.
I couldn't believe that.
Hi.
Hi Cutie.
Huh?
She is in love with you.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
and I'll be in love with her until the day she takes the,
the good part of my cheerio's.
Alright.
Hi.
How are you,
Cutie.
All right,
daddy has to talk filthy so I can still buy your diapers.
That's how it works.
I'm sorry I'm too far down this road to pretend that you have a respectable
dead.
All right,
lovely ladies.
Well,
I mean,
I thought that you were going to try to defend your position and you didn't you
like,
yeah,
I did that.
That's what I did.
I mean,
that's,
that's really all there is to say.
I want the meet along the long you're doing Donald Trump right now.
What does that,
that's how he got out of stuff.
You said all this stuff about women and he's like,
no,
I said that about Rosie O'donnell.
And they were like,
no,
you said that about other women.
He was like,
Hey,
probably right.
It's like,
all right.
I thought that was going to be a big funny fight and it was nothing out.
You're on my ankle.
Okay.
All right ladies.
Bye Bye.
Can you say bye bye
bye bye.
All right.
Oh well yeah,
I'll see you later.
Okay.
You get my sake and I get it cheaper later.
Let me guess.
Mcdonald's,
what do you guys want?
What do you like Betty?
Like Mcdonald's or Burger King?
I,
but I've always been a McDonald's guy.
Oh,
he's been Mcdonald's and it's not like I'm out here looking for another
advertiser.
I'll tell you right now,
I feel the best poisoned in fast food is Mcdonald's.
This is how I would,
I would rank this how I ranked my fast food cheeseburgers.
Nia.
All right.
As much as there's some great ones out there like in and out.
I have to go to Mcdonald's cause the child's sense memory,
you know,
that just takes me back to,
when my bicycle was orange,
just like my hair that I used to have and I had the white tape around the handle
bars.
Huh?
Tell you what happened.
I went to the,
um,
to see my trainer and when I got in there,
oh yeah.
Did you take the Best Matt in the gym?
Yes.
And he was finishing up with another client and she had her daughter there who
was like four years old and she's so cute.
So I was like,
oh,
you want to see pictures of my baby?
And so I was showing her pictures of the baby and then she saw a picture of you
with the baby and she goes,
who's that?
And I said,
Oh that's,
I'm her daddy,
that's my husband.
And she goes,
okay.
She goes,
why doesn't he have any hair?
Who said that the kid can the for her all?
And I said,
well,
you know,
sometimes when people get older,
their hair starts to come out.
And so he just decided to cut it off because he didn't want it just to be
falling out.
And I think it looks better this way.
And she was like,
yeah,
that's true.
Why did I need to know that there was a cute already feel bad enough about
myself?
Do you want me to,
kids have looked at me and said,
you're ugly in my life.
At least six.
No,
I swear to God,
we,
when I had hair,
yeah,
children and children are honest.
What do y'all,
you adults would do and you just be a nice to me,
maybe you deserve that bone in Ribeye and just give me the ship by Ai.
Yeah.
Ugly piece of Shit.
Get out of here.
Meaning like that.
Yeah.
Cute story now.
I met this girl the other day and she,
I showed her a picture of you and she was like,
hey,
why is your butt's so big?
And I was like,
well,
you know,
you bought isn't big.
All right,
but if not,
I'm going to fucking pay for either.
You're going to laugh at that and I'm going to pay for that comment forever.
Yeah,
right.
You could just,
you could just eviscerate me.
I,
first of all,
I didn't say anything.
It was just child that said it.
So I don't know why you're making up some scenario where someone's insulting.
Like my looks,
that's not a child.
And for the record,
my ass might be big,
but it's like perfect.
So it is,
it's why I married you with certain wasn't certainly wasn't the other end.
There are other end.
I have no problem with the,
if she for fucking Yap,
that drives me up the wall.
Alright.
Whatever.
Why,
why?
Why do I try to make a point?
Why do I try to get ahead?
They know what I mean.
It's just like,
Bill,
you're losing.
Okay.
You're at a casino in the house.
Always wins in the house.
Did you fucking wife?
So just fucking cash in your chips and go back to the Goddamn Room.
Anyways,
let's get back to the NHL playoffs.
Congratulations to the fucking expansion.
Tampa lightening.
I don't hate you guys cause I love Steve Byars him and I know he's in your front
office so I'm happy for him.
All right.
Okay.
Having said that,
you guys were the better team no matter how bad the officiating was.
It was bad for both sides.
Um,
and no matter what,
I think you guys still,
you should,
you just were a better tape.
You just were a better team no matter what you were going to win.
But I will say this,
this officiating straight across the board in the NHL playoffs,
not just arguing for my team has been really a unprofessional,
really unprofessional.
There's always a couple of calls here or there,
but like,
it's reminding me of NBA officiating last decade when I called it,
I said it was fixed.
I'm not saying it's fixed,
this is coming off more like,
I feel like it's like,
did the real refs go on strike?
And these are like some fucking scab refs.
They pulled out of the fucking crowd.
Um,
it was just a couple of like,
look,
you know,
Marshawn took that guy's fucking knees out.
They didn't make a call there,
which I thought was bullshit.
And uh,
you know,
I know we were licking people's faces and this is no rule against that yet.
I can guarantee you maybe now that the Bruins are knocked out,
maybe they'll,
they'll relax.
But I mean,
I thought if we advanced to the next round,
they were going to make a quick rule that's going to be called the Marshawn
rural and it's going to be no player Shell,
kiss,
lick tongue or in any manner at use his facial or a fist
to with inappropriate contact.
There's going to be the,
there's gotta be the Brad Marshawn rule and someday if I live enough,
I will see Brad when he's in his seventies on the NHL Network,
laughing about it,
talking about how that rule came about and why he was doing what he was doing.
Um,
it's the most bizarre thing I've ever seen.
And it was,
it was,
it was hilarious when they went back to the,
to studio,
Jeremy Ronek was,
is it was like,
it happened to him.
He's like,
I would have immediately gone to the showers and I was thinking like,
oh,
that's great.
You're all of fame player.
Let's get you off the ice.
Um,
I had a buddy of mine actually texted me,
said,
not even Sean Avery licked and other player and I was like,
yeah,
well he was too dumb to think of it.
And he goes,
well,
if he's that dumb is he married to a supermodel?
And I said,
all right,
fair enough.
You got me.
Um,
anyways,
but just,
you know,
I mean,
what the fuck that guy,
the guy in Tampa,
like we really needed to win game four so we can lose in six games and it was
still going to lose the fucking Tampa is his hands off his stick.
He hauls McAvoy down behind his own net,
behind his own fucking net.
No call.
It was,
it was the most obvious.
Did Not only did the announces,
when they went back to the fucking studio even,
they were like,
what the fuck?
Tampa takes it,
pass it over stamp coast and they tie the fucking game up and Wheaton instead of
having a chance to even this series at two two we go down three one it was just
stuff like that.
I,
you know,
it's funny,
as Bart,
nick was in Tampa Bay and he was listening to it on the radio and Esposito said
that it looked like a dive,
which is the funniest fucking thing ever.
Esposito is still fucking pissed that he asked for like $3 more from the cheap
ass Boston Bruins 45 years ago and they ship them to New York,
our archrival other than the Canadians during that time.
So he will never be impartial when it comes to us.
But what the fuck?
Who the fuck is going to dive behind their own net with the puck behind your own
fucking net when you're up by one and you have to win that playoff game?
Are you going to go down three games to one?
I don't know.
He is Esposito.
He is a hall of Famer,
but that did not look like a dive to me.
And having said all this fucking sour grape shit,
I know Tampa's still would've won.
I know they probably would have wanted to.
Probably six games is what I think would have happened.
They just had too much fire power.
And I think by the time we decided to get physical in the series it was too
late.
But um,
that's what was missing in our game this year I think against Toronto and
against Tampa,
which both of them I felt had more firepower than we did is when you're playing
a team that has,
you know,
as faster than you and has more gold scores,
you have to get physical with them.
You can't just let them fucking skate around it.
I think we just waited too long.
But I haven't said that this rebuild is on an upswing.
I mean,
I thought that we were going to be bad for a good six,
seven seasons.
I didn't the light at the end of the tunnel.
So I'm very happy that we,
uh,
we want to play off series advanced to the second round.
Definitely a very successful year and we're going to have a new rule named after
one of our players to Marshawn rule.
Maybe it's a good thing that we lost in five.
If there was any more games,
he might've been the first guy to get a fucking meat to case from another guy,
right?
Oh No,
no.
Wait,
that one guy did.
The agent did with the other guy from the cop show.
All right.
I guess everything's been done.
Is that what it is?
Has everything been done in the whole time?
This is what kills me is I'm watching the Bruins,
you know,
just fucking losing this series,
licking people's faces and shit and I have,
I've missed every single second of the Celtic 76 you know,
I just,
I had to pick a road.
I'm so busy,
I've got the kid and all that and I only had time and I missed I guess one of
the most epic Celtics Games in recent memory where they tied it up at the buzzer
against the sixes and then came back and won in overtime.
All I'm hearing is
Rosier Tatum Brown,
how much they're stepping up.
Al Horford I guess was a blocking shots like a maniac.
And uh,
so now I gotta go,
um,
I gotta I gotta say I have,
I have all the time in the world to watch the Celtics now.
So that's what I kind of realized.
You know,
as much as I love the Celtics and everything,
I really am a hockey guy because I knew we were going to lose that series and I
still hung in there and watched it.
Although I missed yesterday's game because I was at a kid birthday party,
an awesome kid.
Birthday party,
like a,
you know,
you know when parents do a kid birthday party,
right?
You take notes.
These people did a great,
they didn't have it at their house.
They had it at like a function room.
There was an outdoor area,
there was a little jumpy house.
This guy did a bubble show,
you know,
he had a good set to man.
That's a tough crowd.
You know,
kids trying to keep them,
you know,
their attention.
They had booze for the parents,
they had great food,
you know,
and then,
uh,
over in the corner they had this area where the kids do,
you know,
one of those playpens that has like a Zillion,
different multicolored balls and all that type of interests.
My kid was totally entertained the whole time.
I don't think I saw any kid crying just until the very end where the kids,
you know,
they need a nap and they just like,
Hey,
I want to do it.
But,
um,
it was a great time.
So,
uh,
somebody there asked me,
he goes,
you Bruins plane right now.
I'm like,
I'm afraid to look.
So I was kind of looking down and looking at the scores and then all my Boston
friends was sending me texts going,
what the fuck are we doing?
These refs sock.
The refs really did suck.
Um,
you know,
who knows?
They probably still would've maybe tied it up and beat his son five.
Who the fuck knows?
But I'm just saying,
you know,
I just hate having that,
like
that goddamn feeling.
You know,
it's like that year the Lakers beat us.
which sucks enough.
But if the Lakers,
it's fine.
I can live with that to the fucking Lakers.
You know what I mean?
But you know,
you call like 30 something flowers on one team and you know,
in the teens on the other and a game seven,
it's just inexcusable.
Unless we were out there hacking people up and it just,
I dunno,
fucking drives me up.
The God,
they,
those are the ones that stay with me.
You know what I mean?
I don't give a fuck if you just come in and kick our ass,
but we don't.
I,
but I,
I do take peace in the fact that the Tampa Bay was definitely the better team
and I feel that the
easily could have just beat us in six.
Um,
as much as I hate to admit that you motherfuckers,
um,
anyways,
plowing ahead.
What's going to go on with the capital's?
The capital's finally going to get over the Hump and slay the dragon and beat
these goddamn penguins from Pittsburgh or the Pittsburgh penguins going to
continue their march to be the first team since the New York Islanders is,
Steve Byrne reminded me yesterday,
it's The New York islanders to win three in a row.
I'd spend that long.
The island is actually won four in a row from 80 to 84.
And um,
I remember them,
they were on the cover the next year of sports illustrated and they said the
strive for five to assume,
you know,
the ray,
one of the rare times sports illustrated portal hockey player back then,
you know,
on the cover.
I think it was Mike Bossy,
if I remember correctly.
And um,
yeah,
that was the age of dynasties when I grew up,
when I think about it from like,
you look at the 70s in hockey Bruins,
one,
two flyers,
two,
and the Canadians one six.
So you had three teams,
basically won everything.
And then the previous decade it was,
it was Canadians,
leafs,
and then the Blackhawks won one.
Um,
and then I think Canadians,
one,
five and,
and the least one four,
cause I want to say the least one like three in a row.
And then one in 67 and the Blackhawks won in [inaudible] 61 and everything else
was the Canadians,
if I remember correctly.
Um,
and then you went to the eighties than the islanders.
So basically after the,
the,
uh,
it went Bruins,
Canadians,
Bruins,
Colleen's flyers,
flyers,
then Canadians,
Canadians,
Canadians and islanders,
islanders,
Edmonton,
Canadians,
Edmonton than Calgary.
Beat the fucking Canadians.
That one of my favorite one,
landing macdonald,
the ginger.
Um,
and then Edmonton again in 90.
And then 91,
92 was the penguins.
And that was like immediate talking a,
I mean,
you could literally go back all the way to the 50s,
cause I know like the Redwings one like to back and everything else was just,
it was just fucking basically pre 1967 if you had to guess who won the cup that
year,
either guests,
Canadians or may beliefs.
Um,
but then all of a sudden,
you know,
once,
they had the expansion six and 67,
and then they added a,
you know,
Edmonton Oilers and all those guys and like I believe 78 or something like that.
And then it was a 28 team league and it just took a little bit.
We'll actually,
the island is where expansion team in the early seventies.
Then they got Allah,
they went on that run.
But uh,
then after that,
after the penguins went back to back,
it's just basically every other year.
It's like somebody else wins it other than the one the Redwings one,
two in a row.
And I think,
uh,
the penguins right now,
right.
It's not how it goes.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
but anyways,
which is why I hate to say this is a Celtics fan.
I think the,
uh,
the Lakers are,
they,
they're the most successful franchise
in the modern era because they were able to during free agency win championships
at a clip that people,
one before,
you know,
back when there was like a,
if you were a Laker you were a lake or go fuck yourself.
You're not going somewhere else unless the owner decides.
Um,
they haven't said that.
You know,
the Lakers do have a championship,
uh,
that,
you know,
there was a mobbed up reference fucked over the Sacramento Kings that year.
I'm not saying the kings would have wanted,
but the Lakers would not have gotten a banner that year.
And then that other one with the fucking 30 something files 37 files in 48
minutes of the Celtics
and never forget Colby.
He goes,
I don't know how we won that game.
Well fucking talk to the guys with the athlete's foot shirts.
Um,
anyways,
sorry,
I'm just in a fucking bad mood cause my team lost.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
Uh,
old Billy,
no vice
trudging along into May.
I want to go at least a weekend of May.
Cause I was just trying to go,
you know,
the,
the month of April,
basically vice lists and then I got into May and then I'm just like,
you know what,
I'm looking good.
I'm keeping the weight off.
I got the Big Five,
oh next month.
It would really be a shame if I got this close to my birthday.
Look in this good.
And then I just,
you know,
I just fucking,
put on that booze 10 pounds.
I don't want to do that.
But,
so,
uh,
I've been laying off,
laying off board as shit
went to that party yesterday.
There was booze there.
Could have had one.
Didn't do it.
Went to the steak house,
said all the beautiful fucking bottles behind the bar.
Didn't do it.
Came home,
trudge,
pass my bar.
They don't even say hi anymore.
Didn't do it.
Went downstairs,
took out my phone,
played solitaire on it,
fell asleep.
The exciting life of sobriety,
you know,
it's hard to was I watched the Kentucky Derby.
Um,
I would have won money cause I always bet on that white haired guys horse.
Cause he's,
he's just a man.
He's the bill Belicheck of that shit.
And a,
the year I went,
the only time I went was that triple crown winner and he owned it.
I won money on that one.
And uh,
I was thinking if I was there,
I,
I always,
I always the Michael McDonald Guy of the horse racing owners and I was just
watching that,
that event.
And I was just,
I was like,
why am I not sitting here right now drinking some bourbon,
smoking a cigar,
right.
Watching it through my front window with the volume turned up.
She can't smoke a cigar in the house,
but I didn't do it.
I just sat there,
you know,
I bought one of those TRX bands,
I'm going to go on the Internet,
still have my custom workout,
you know,
uh,
my shoulder feels really good to really strong.
Uh,
I still haven't done a pull up and like two years.
Uh Oh actually,
no,
I did.
And then reinjured it,
you know,
six months ago.
So now rehabbing it back.
So now I'm trying to go nice and frigging slow.
I got these bands.
Now I'm back into doing yoga.
I'm not fucking j good or not smoking and outboard shit mice there.
I set it.
I'm fucking bored shitless.
I like people who are sober.
How the fuck
you know,
you know what?
I actually finally I bought an external,
a little CD player to plug in so I could finally do my,
uh,
my Rosetta Stone French and um,
I've been doing that.
Then of course,
you know,
okay.
My wife helps me set the fucking thing up and then I,
uh,
you know,
it's working,
I'm having a great time and then I go to use it again and of course it won't
fucking work.
It doesn't recognize anything.
I don't know how to open it up and it's just a fucking pain in the ass.
So hopefully at some point she'll take some time out of our day,
but anyways,
I'm going to polish up on that shit and try to do an hour or two every single
day right up until I get over to France.
I just want to get a little bit better with my shit.
But,
uh,
you know,
at some point I gotta,
I gotta I gotta learn,
I gotta become fluent in French because I just think a fucking moron like me
knowing how to speak French,
it's just something,
it's too funny to not do it right.
Um,
okay.
I've actually ordered kids French books and I'm reading them to my daughter.
Those are great cause I'm sick of like,
well how did I learn how to read English and speak it?
You know,
I had those little books being in Sandy.
Sandy had been,
remember them.
Did they still have those fucking books?
They were like these dogs.
That's what that is really is one of the most fascinating things ever is
learning how to read.
And you're a kid so you don't really remember like somebody like teaches you how
to fucking read.
All right,
let me see sandy and being,
they were a dog and a cat.
See this man,
I'm going back 45 years,
Shani and being books.
I swear to God,
if I see these,
this is going to freak me out to see these books.
And of course it's not coming up.
Come on you.
I the slowest goddamn Internet ever.
Oh,
they don't even have them anymore.
Stanley being some guys,
Stanley Bing wrote a book,
a hundred bullshit jobs and how to get them.
That is fucking hilarious.
Why the hell would you do that?
Why?
Why would you,
oh my God.
Look at this book.
The Ben,
the Bernstein bears in the mean drunk
and is uh,
does a bear,
I swear to God,
wearing a wife beater holding a bat and looks like a bottle of Jack Daniels.
This is why you got to love the Internet.
I'm looking up a kid's book
and I find a hundred bullshit jobs and how to get them in the Bernstein bears.
Am I saying that right?
And the mean drunk
Bingo.
Crosby.
Hannah,
some bugs bunny one.
All right.
Sorry.
What the fuck mean?
You guys are literally listened to me surf the Goddamn Internet.
Um,
I've been doing a bunch of standup and popping in a bunch of places out here
getting ready for the gigs I have coming up that I do not deserve to be doing in
Ireland and in London,
Dublin in London.
So I'm going to make sure I'm beyond on my game when I do those things.
I have a,
uh,
a run of dates coming up in San Francisco Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
Friday.
I'm going to be up there with Nate Kraig Milwaukee Bucks Fan.
I'm not going to rub it in unless he brings it up.
Um,
and I'll be,
I'll be up there all week,
going to find a studio space with the drum kit.
I'm going to fucking practice that bullshit.
I'm be doing my French and I'm not going to be drinking and I'm not going to be
smoking cigars.
Uh,
boy,
I don't know.
I,
there's no fucking way I'm going to do this.
I guess this is why people who are,
you know,
somebody asked me that the day if I wanted to go to a meeting,
you know what I mean?
And I was just like,
dude,
I can't sit there with all this fucking donuts and people smoking cigarettes.
I'm just,
you know what I mean?
I'm just not,
I'm not that,
you know,
like I'm,
I mean everything I ever fucking joined,
I was like,
I'm not this,
I'm liking this,
but I'm not quite this.
Even like playing drums.
As much as I love playing drums,
I know I'm not a musician.
Like when I go,
you see,
you know,
when you really see somebody that has the fucking gift,
do you like,
that's what that is.
I mean,
I can try to do this and make a really difficult life for myself.
It wasn't until I walked into a comedy club in open Mike and I saw all those
desperate lunatics and I'm like,
yeah,
this is,
this is me.
I'm this,
this is what I am.
So I went to an AA meeting,
I've gone to a couple of them.
Um,
they were required by the fucking courts of Massachusetts.
I was required to go to two of those in a mother against drinking and driving
way back in the day when I got arrested for that shit back in the 80s,
you know?
MMM.
And I remember sitting there listening to these fucking stories and I was just
like,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah.
These people would have like head wounds and wake up from head wounds or stumble
out of jail barefoot and just stumble across the street directly over to a
liquor store.
I mean,
that is a fucking alcoholic.
You know,
they need help.
Okay.
To Stop.
I can stop on my own.
I might just justifying all of this.
That's what I'd be in the programs could be.
I can stop on my own and I just sit here and I'm just fucking budgets born out
of my fucking mind.
It doesn't make any sense.
It's like I'm saying,
that's like saying I'm never going to have ice cream ever again.
It's like ever I could see not having it all the time,
seeing out of fat,
fuck,
I get dad so your teeth don't rot out of your fucking head.
I was definitely drinking too much,
but like,
okay,
I'm never going to have it again.
I'm gonna go to go to the Kentucky Derby against someday.
God fucking willing.
I'm going to go to the Kentucky Derby again and I'm going to sit there stone
sober.
I mean,
you go into the track.
I mean right there,
you're a degenerate.
Why not give into it?
I don't know.
Who knows?
But I will tell you,
I do love it in the morning when I wake up.
Clearheaded in the morning,
it might pasty stomach is nice and flat.
I definitely,
I definitely enjoy that.
You know,
makes me a better dad.
I always make my daughter breakfast.
That's my thing every morning,
right?
I'd go out and I get her,
I opened the door and she goes,
hi,
am I gay?
All right.
Excuse me.
Nice hug and a kiss.
Then,
uh,
you know,
change or put a pajama bottoms across your eyes.
Where is she,
where she plays that game?
Loves it.
Still loving that game.
Right.
And um,
can I go upstairs?
She's really easy.
I cut up bananas,
strawberries and blueberries.
Did I make her a couple of eggs scrambled?
Yeah,
it's funny.
What I like to do is I like to have it all prepared before I bring her upstairs.
Because if I do,
you know,
cause if she's just sitting there,
she starts to get restless,
like,
you know,
where's the food?
But if I have it all,
yeah.
Ready.
The other day I had it already,
you know,
and I brought her up and I put her in every little chair and I put a bib on and
all that.
And then they put the plate down already ready and everything made.
And she just goes,
wow.
No.
She goes,
Whoa,
it was awesome.
And she can feed herself.
Only thing I got to watch out for her,
she,
she wolfs down food the way I do.
So I just got to make sure I'm a
staying on her,
so I make sure I cut up everything nice and small,
spread out the eggs.
So they cool off.
She doesn't burn them off and then that's it.
Give her a glass of water,
then it's all good.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
you know,
and I guess if I was hung over and it'd probably be a bad thing.
So then I think to myself,
what if I just get shit faced when I'm on the road among,
on the road like four days a month?
That would be fine.
Right.
What do you guys say about that?
I will.
What do you say?
Oh,
you guys and fucking Aa and I don't drink on the plane.
It's just after the shows.
It's gotta be a way to do it the way I used to be able to do it,
you know?
Do you know,
you know what to really think that that fucked me up was I,
I,
I never used to have booze in the house.
So that's the problem.
So when I do start drinking again,
because I am going to start drinking,
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to finish all the liquor in my house,
which even if I drank at a degenerate level,
would probably take me a good six months.
So I don't,
I don't know how I'm going to judge.
Probably should have some people over and help them kill some of these bottles,
but I have such good booze.
I just can't give it away to some bomb,
you know what I mean?
Like,
do you ever give a Cuban cigar to some guy who occasionally smokes and you just
watch them,
which is half the whole fucking thing down.
And you know,
you might as well give him a Dutch master.
That's the kind of booze I have.
So what I would like to do is slowly knock out all the booze over the next five
years that I have in the house and not replace any of the bottles.
And then,
because I think even back in the day when I lived in New York,
when I was living in New York and Derosa was living in New York,
um,
I mean we used to just get fucking annihilated
and uh,
but I never had any booze in the house.
So in my apartment I should say.
So I think that that's,
I think that's right.
There was the game changers when I had it at home and then had these nice
fucking glasses.
You know,
when you really get into it,
like this is high level booze and these high level,
like you know,
the right glass and you get into the whole like ritual of it and you really can
trick yourself.
That should not just be in some degenerate drinking alone.
You know what I mean?
You'll use as a high ball glass and this is what you,
this was also those glass.
Here's for us,
Sam Adams beer actually have the Sam Adams classes.
You know what,
that little lip at the top,
like it's supposed to make the head and the hops and all of that tastes good.
It tastes the fucking same.
You know what I mean?
That's equity.
They do all these reissues of guitars.
You know what I mean?
I can't tell the difference the way I play guitar,
which I barely do anymore.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
you could give me the greatest guitar in the world.
I'm still going to sound like make,
which is shitty.
So anyways,
I don't know who the fuck knows.
Um,
but a buddy of mine's actually been listening to these tapes that,
you know,
talk about alcohol,
not in that stupid you need to go to get help type of way,
but they just talk about,
they just put it in a different perspective.
Um,
I dunno,
I'm just like a streaky person.
That's all it is.
So like when I'm not drinking,
I don't want to drink because I don't want to ruin the streak.
Oh my God,
man.
I've gotten like 35,
40 days here.
I'm going to start all over again.
Let me see if I can make it to 50,
because there's a big part of me that,
um,
you know,
we'd like to plow right through my birthday and not drink,
but then I was like,
I'm going to be in France.
How the fuck do you not drink when you're over there?
I'm not gonna have a fucking glass of wine.
Sit there like a fucking jerk off.
I Dunno.
We'll see.
Anyways.
Alright.
Zip Recruiter,
Zip
but crewed up.
Talk about the challenge of finding great talent and how the way you went about
it just did not work.
I was inefficient.
Well,
I'd love to tell you that that was a problem.
But,
uh,
I actually got lucky for somebody who was a fan of my podcast,
reached out to me by the name of Andrew [inaudible] and I've been working with
them ever since,
you know.
Okay.
And He's been great.
So I don't know what to tell you to separate zip recruiter knew there was a
smarter way.
Well,
look,
obviously if I actually ran a business where I needed more than one frigging
employee,
okay.
And I don't want to waste time bringing people in and sitting there talking to
them and trying to find out if they came from divorce or you know,
how they did in school or go go check their Goddamn Facebook page to see what
they've liked or not liked.
Um,
this seems the easiest way to do it.
And you can just sift,
sift through a entire,
the entire nation of qualified candidates,
while Ziprecruiter knew that there was a smarter way.
So they built a platform that finds the right job,
job candidates for you,
chip
learns what you're looking for,
identifies people with the right experience.
And invites them to apply to your job.
These invitations that have revolutionized how you find your next hire.
In fact,
80% of employees who post jobs on zip
get a quality candidate through the site.
It just one day and zip recruiter doesn't stop there.
They even spotlight the strongest applications you received,
so you never miss a great match.
That's right.
Oh,
sorry.
The right candidates are out there.
Sip
is how you find them.
Call to action.
Businesses of all tries his trust,
ZipRecruiter for their hiring needs.
Right now.
My listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free.
That's right.
Free.
Just go to
ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's ziprecruiter.com/burr sip,
recruiter.com/burr.
They're going to do it again.
Zip.
Well,
the smartest way to hire I gotta to say my voice here cause I'm going to record
some efforts of family.
F is for Fucko today.
All right,
movement,
MVMT movement watches.
Spring is right around the corner and movement is dropping all new sunglasses to
get your ready is dropping all new sunglasses to get you ready for the warmer
weather.
Um,
we just got our goto shades for it all.
Who's we?
Is that them?
Is that supposed to be me?
The guys that movement don't just make great watches.
They also make awesome sunglasses and just realized a ton of new styles.
I'll just re released a ton of new styles.
What is wrong with me today?
Um,
all right.
Here's my problem with sunglasses.
Evidentaly I got all these cheap pairs that look terrible.
No,
I don't.
I have nice sunglasses.
I have a couple cheapos and I fucking ate those.
But every time I buy a $200 pair,
I feel like I get ripped off.
That's not the truth.
Every time I spent $200,
I ended up fucking losing it.
Or sitting on them are dropping them on the pavement.
Well our friends at movement.
Yeah,
the watch guys,
they kind of felt the same way.
So they thought screw it.
Oh,
they're getting,
they're getting dangerous here.
How about we make quality trendy glasses at a fair price?
These things aren't plastic.
Yeah,
they're acetate acetate.
You can get them polarized.
Isn't there enough of that on Facebook?
And they just start at $70 they are seriously going to be your goto shades.
These are high quality premium Acetate,
Acetate,
high acetate frames,
no cheap plastic here.
You got to see these.
They have lots of styles to choose from.
Classy,
trendy,
round aviator mirrored polarized for him or for her.
You're sure to find the perfect pair.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to [inaudible]
dot com slash burr you know movement for how they've revolutionized the watch
industry.
Now's the time to check out this sunglasses.
Go to movement.com/burr join the movement.
All Shit,
the black Tux,
everybody like the Ohio State University.
This is the black Tux.
These are the Tuxedos that those people on Ohio state were wearing when they
sold their jerseys and it got put on suspension.
Wedding season is upon us.
Oh that's right.
It is.
You're going to be doing it big and going out to all of your buddies weddings.
I gotta be honest with you.
Weddings are actually great now.
Wedding sucked when I was a kid cause he was still like,
people weren't making them individually.
They just were all the same.
They will long and fucking boring.
And you were like,
when can we get to the bar?
Uh,
when you're bringing a date,
you want to look fresh,
but it has to be convenient.
That's where the black tux comes in to it.
You're not even in the wedding and you're going to wear a Tuxedo to the wedding.
That's fucking hilarious.
Going out dress the groom.
I like the way these people are thinking.
The black tops has awesome suits and Tuxedos and all kinds of styles and you
rent them online.
Oh I get it.
You gonna wear a suit.
The,
the black Tux offers the kinds of suits and Tuxedos styles that would normally
be wildly expensive to buy.
You might only wear it once like
the Emerald Shawl Tuxedo.
It's Funky,
it's cool.
But how many times you get aware and Emerald Green Tuxedo with the Black Tux?
You can,
you can do you and blow it out for you.
One big event,
you're going to wear an amber or green Tuxedo to somebody else's wedding.
You know,
when you do that,
you do that.
When you,
you used to be fucking the bride,
you know,
and she's doing that Douche move of inviting an old boyfriend to the wedding.
Brigid's friends.
We're at a good place.
By the way,
as a man,
you can not allow that to happen.
You cannot allow that to happen.
I mean,
I,
I would actually question whether I would even marry the person if they're
inviting an old boyfriend,
uh,
with the Black Tux free home,
try on,
you can see the fit and feel the quality of the suit months before your event.
Well,
you better make sure you eat well if you're going to try it on that early after
ordering your sue will arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything is less than perfect.
If you put it on a few pounds,
it took a few off.
I guess the Black Tux will send you a replacement right away.
Oh,
that's cool.
I remember I'll simple returns are where it turned heads than send it back three
days after your event.
Shipping is free both ways.
Stand out at your event for the right reasons.
With the Black Tux to get $20 off your purchase,
visit the black Tux dot coms slash for that's the black
tux.com/per for $20 off your purchase.
The black Tux premium rental suits and Tuxedos delivered.
All right,
one more.
Here we go.
stamps.com the u s postal service is an important tool for any business.
stamps.com brings all the amazing services of the US Postal Service right to
your fingertips,
to your fingertips.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer stamps.com makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale that automatically calculates the exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the best class of mail based on your
needs.
No need to lease an expensive postage meter and there are no long term
commitments.
I use stamps.com uh,
because uh,
you know,
whenever I send out my postage,
which by the way,
you got to see the poster for my tour coming up,
which is simply called 50.
All right,
the big five o people.
Um,
and I am actually sending posters over to Dublin and over to London.
That's the first place the posters with the tour officially gets kicked off.
Um,
and I actually am not going to be using stamps.com for that just because the
company's going to be sending it out themselves.
However,
when they send me the rest of the posters and I,
when I do Minnesota and all that,
I will be using stamps.com and right then I'm a moron if I can figure it out.
So can you in right now,
you too can enjoy stamps.
The stamps.com service with a special offer that includes a four week trial plus
postage and did a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerthatstamps.com and to burr.
And by the way,
uh,
in Dublin and in London,
I will be coming out after the show to take pictures and sign your posts or
something like that.
I have not done in fucking years.
Um,
I'm gonna do that again because a,
I appreciate you guys coming out.
It is a big birthday.
Why not?
You know,
and God knows I'm not in the back drinking.
Whew.
Although I think once I get through Dublin and once I get through London,
I think,
you know,
that's would be June 6th.
I think that's the night.
I might actually have a little,
uh,
a little stumped and who knows?
I don't know.
But you don't bring in my whole family over there.
I can't be hung over.
That's another reason why my daughter's the best.
Right?
She keeps me sober.
All right,
hang on one second.
I have to look something up here because now we're going to get into the
questions this week and I'm disappointed.
Somebody bringing
some point that somebody bringing up above guns and they're doing it in the
usual way that people do it on the Internet where they insult the other person.
And I just want to make sure I have the definition of something up here.
Okay.
Bullshit.
Ar 15 response to goat guy.
For those of you who don't listen all the time.
Um,
you know,
I,
there's a whole gun debate.
Why do you need an Ar 15?
So I was asking people that have a,
our 15th.
I said,
why do you have one?
Don't give me that bullshit about fucking,
you know,
home defense and all of that crap.
I Made Jesus Christ.
I mean,
you,
you could be,
I mean,
you could literally have a 22
who the fuck anybody want to get shot by a fucking 22?
I would have a 22 I did a whole bit on that just because I don't want to fucking
blow my ear drums out.
Okay.
I mean,
a fucking BB gun.
Yeah.
With one of those little fucking CO2 cartridges,
you shoot somebody in the fucking face with that.
They know what they're gonna do.
They're gonna keep going to keep walking through that.
Then go down the street and just don't have to worry about anything when they
walk into that house.
I don't know.
Anyways,
but you know,
or to fight off the government.
That's my,
another famous want.
No,
that's another my other favorite one.
You're going to fight off the government with your fucking semiautomatic gun
here.
The whole government.
You're going to fight them all off.
Um,
I got a lot of bullets,
mother fucker.
All right.
So anyways,
so this guy ends up writing in saying that he,
uh,
was a sheep farmer or whatever,
goat farm or something like that.
Go farmer and he uses the milk to make a,
um,
Parmigiano Reggiano and he also your some whatever the fuck he used two
different types of cheese.
I forget what the other kid,
but both delicious types of cheese and there's all these coyotes,
they hunt hunted packs and he's shooting at a moving target and it just made
fucking sense.
So then somebody else wrote back,
God,
that's bullshit.
Just get some fucking dogs.
They'll fight off the coyotes,
coyotes,
a cowards,
this guy's full of shit.
And to be randomly killing coyotes like that is,
you know,
mean and all that.
So this guy is responding to the person that responded to the guy because I was
impressed with that guy when he said that,
this is why I use it.
I'll go with,
oh shit,
that makes sense.
And I like that cheese.
So God bless you.
Kill those coyotes.
Right?
Um,
so my name's this guys responding to the person that said that that guy's still
didn't need the gun.
He could just get a couple of dogs.
So anyways,
he said,
hey bill,
I'd like to say to the guys response about just by dogs instead of an ar 15 does
not know what the fuck he's talking about.
First of all,
it's not a machine gun.
You dumb cunt.
It's semiautomatic rifle.
Meaning you pulled the trigger once in one bullet fires.
Okay,
now do you see how he just made his point?
It's not a machine gun.
You dumb cunt.
It's a semiautomatic rifle.
You should say it's not a machine gun.
It's semiautomatic.
And then you should explain what semiotic Madec meets.
All right.
Semiautomatic doesn't just mean that you just pulled the trigger in one bullet
fires because then literally a fucking 38 is semiautomatic.
Doesn't that mean like you can,
you can actually pull the trigger quickly faster
where it won't get jammed or something like,
I mean there's something different between just some fucking revolver,
semiautomatic in fully automatic.
I don't know shit about guns,
right,
but isn't there.
So I looked up semiautomatic firearm.
It says this,
without calling anybody a dumb cunt,
he just not informed.
There's a lot of information in the world.
You can't have it all between your ears,
semiautomatic firearm or a self-loading firearm is one that not only fires a
bullet each time the trigger is pulled but also performs all steps necessary to
prepare it to discharge.
Again,
assuming cartridges remain in the firearm feed device,
typically this includes extracting and ejecting the spent cartridge case from
the firing chamber.
Reconquering the firing mechanism and loading a new cartridge into the fire
firing chamber to fire again,
the trigger is released
to fire again.
The trigger is released and repressed again.
All right,
so now let me ask you this.
So is is a 38
because the revolver turns,
is that considered semiautomatic?
Now I'm just confused.
Semiautomatic,
let me look up.
Let me look.
Let me look this up.
It's a revolver.
You know it's funny.
People were in the gun right now.
The amount of people that are listening to me like I'm a fucking moron.
Like this means that they're better at math.
It's like I don't know guns.
I don't know anything about this shit.
If you didn't know anything about drums I would make fun of you cause you didn't
want to fucking high hat.
Was it a revolver?
Semiautomatic,
let's see here.
Any hits search and it takes two hours.
A revolver which uses multiple chambers and a single barrel and a derringer
which uses multiple chambers in multiple barriers.
Also fire one round per trigger pull,
but achieved this in different ways and as such are not classified as being
semiautomatic,
semiautomatic pistols.
You semi automatic pistol
is a type of pistol that is semiautomatic.
I swear to God.
That's the first statement.
Meaning it uses the energy of the fired cartridge to cycle the action of the
firearm and advanced the next available cartridge into position.
So basically,
if I don't have some revolutionary war thing that it's just like I put a bullet
in shoot and then put another bullet in,
or I don't have to do that cocking thing that you always see with the sniper
rifles.
Yeah.
All right.
So this is sort of a basic gun that,
yeah,
it's just like a car with power windows and power brakes,
power steering,
like most cars have that now.
Is that basically what you're saying when you were calling guy at dumb cunt,
he's not a dumb cunt.
I bet that deck wanted this game.
What if he's a veterinarian?
It doesn't mean you're a dumb cunt.
All right.
He should have said you uninformed comment.
How about that?
Can we,
can we meet in the middle there and can still call him a cunt,
but just used to correct an adjective?
MMM.
Anyways,
just like most rifles and hand guns these days.
Oh,
you actually explained it to me if I considered continued reading.
Okay.
Uh,
first of all,
it's not a machine gun.
You'd dump con it's a semiautomatic rifle.
May you pull the trigger once in one bullet fires.
Just like most rifle in hand guns these days right off the bat.
You know,
this guy doesn't know what he's talking about and probably never shot a gun in
his life.
Fair enough.
That's all good.
I usually wouldn't be this hostile,
but hey,
I had a few drinks and I'm passionate about this subject.
All right,
fair enough.
Uh,
anyway,
I believe his argument was to buy a fleet of dogs to protect your livestock.
He didn't say a fleet.
He said,
you know,
I get like two or three.
He said,
get the fuck Outta here.
You know,
expensive train dogs are to protect your livestock.
I'm well do you,
are you just drunk at a bar of throwing this out?
I make Christ purebred German shepherds are eight to $900 around here.
Now you're a moron.
No one's getting that German shepherd.
Did you get like a fucking cheap dog era?
Uh,
uh,
Christ one of my buddies as one of those dogs,
they're smart as shit.
I forget the name of the dog.
You wouldn't get seen.
And now you don't know about dogs.
He had dumb cunt.
You uninformed cut.
God knows what a fucking fleet of dogs costs.
Not to mention the food and attention.
You have to give him a Ar.
15 prices are going down every day.
And with Amma,
well under 50 cents around,
you'd have to be a dumb ass.
Oh,
Jesus.
Parentheses or liberal not to use this.
All right.
And right there,
your whole argument is out the window.
Anybody who classifies all conservatives or Republicans are all liberals and
Democrats is morons right there.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's kind of like what I was doing earlier when I was talking about how bad
the officiating was.
Yeah.
Against the Bruins.
However,
I did bring up that,
you know,
Marshawn should've got a fucking misconduct for taking that guy's knees up.
Um,
and I did say that straight across the board.
It was,
it's been really fucking unprofessional.
Um,
however,
but if I were to just sit there and say,
all the bad calls went against us.
I mean,
I don't know.
I would beat that.
I mean,
what,
what kind of fucking world kind of do a match or liberal.
And I just made him out to all be Southern's.
Like everybody south is a dumb ass,
which is not true.
Mark Twain,
you know what I mean?
That guy was so smart.
He wrote all those books in Kentucky,
Fried Chicken,
had that guy dressed.
Just like in conclusion,
he said,
in conclusion,
as if he sees he's made this great argument,
uh,
I think there is a huge lack of education on firearms in the u s today.
And he actually wrote in the US today,
he didn't capitalize the u s um,
I would 100% agree with that.
At the end of the day,
the Ar 15 is the most effective tool for a lot of jobs.
A PSA saw you in Nashville,
your final bit fucking killed.
Love you and go fuck yourself sincerely.
Your freedom loving fans in Nashville.
Ah,
dude.
You know something?
I gotta be honest with you.
I agreed with your points,
but when you said dumb ass or liberal and the fact that you said freedom,
loving,
like who doesn't love to be free?
You know what I mean?
Are you another one of these peace people that thinks that isis is a major
threat to a first world country with their no plane,
no boat,
no uniform,
no real weaponry,
modern weaponry,
fucking army.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Do you think if isis was,
uh,
living in the bad lands,
we would even waste a fucking second of our goddamn tax dollars to try and stop
them?
This plenty of fucking cops out there that just not sitting on top of a bunch of
fucking oil freedom.
Loving fucking,
you know,
something you've really,
you've really lost me there.
I mean,
if you don't agree with me,
I guess she just don't like freedom.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
What I,
the amount of people that are drinking that fucking Koolaid 15 years into this
fucking thing,
it's a liberation.
They have weapons of mass destruction.
They've changed it like 90 fucking times.
And I'm so sick of the fact that you can't criticize what the fuck were those
fucking broke ass console over there are going to bankrupt us.
How long can you spend $700 billion a fucking year.
At some point we're going to have to pay for that.
I'm going to have to pay for it.
You're going to pay for it.
Our kids,
their kids and all of that.
Jesus fucking Christ over a bunch of jerk offs with a bag of m eighties
yeah.
Unfucking believable.
Unbelievable.
You know why we're over there.
Saddam knew why we went over there.
He lit it on fire before we got there,
but you can't say that anymore in this country because if you do,
that means you're in Isis or you're a socialist or some shit like that.
It's just fucking,
it's unbelievable.
It's unfucking believable be while this place is going to hell in a handbasket
with a nationwide heroin epidemic,
our food supply is fucking poison and the got the houses back so they can cook
the economy again.
All of that is fine.
All of that is fine,
but if you tell jokes that have fucking
presidential,
whatever the fuck that is,
the whole goddamn world stops.
All right.
This girl,
ah,
Billy blowfish,
love you,
Billy blue.
I like that.
Love your podcast.
I've been listening to it every time I'm in the car.
Driving to and from work definitely makes my commute better.
Listen,
I'm a 22 year old guy and I've been talking to this girl who has a kid.
Now I know what you're thinking.
What the fuck is going through?
Your stupid fucking had a,
but the problem is is I think I really liked this girl.
I don't think that's a problem.
As long as you're willing to take on the responsibilities of that relationship
is nothing wrong with it.
And I,
one thing I forgot to mention,
I haven't even met her in person yet.
Ah,
okay.
I just,
I just dropped the microphone on that one.
I'm supposed to meet her.
I was supposed to meet up with there.
Okay.
I just thought you was stalking her on social media.
I'm supposed to meet her.
I'm supposed to go meet her up this Saturday.
Is that a new expression?
I think you said you think he meant to say meet up with there this Saturday
night after work and I'm not sure what will happen.
The thing is she's exactly like me.
She's vegetarian,
she likes animals and nature,
etc.
Etc.
What's the Nashville Guy doing right now?
Yeah,
she likes all that.
But
um,
but she has a fucking kid bill.
I'm fucking 22 years old and can't stop thinking about this girl who has a
fucking kid.
Please give me some advice.
I'm not sure how to proceed.
Well I think you're very concerned with the responsibilities of the fact that
she has a kid and what that's gonna mean and you're only 22 years old and
there's fucking nothing wrong with that.
Okay.
And don't let all these fucking don't don't ask a woman about this cause she's
just going to stick up for the fucking woman because she's kind of insert
herself into that situation would be like,
well I'd still like to be able to find love just cause I have a kid to,
you're 22 years old,
you are a kid.
All right.
Unless you're like really mature or something like that,
that that is a major,
uh,
detail that you should be thinking about.
All right?
So,
uh,
I would respect the fact that there's a voice in your head that's saying,
dude,
she's got a fucking kid.
All right.
Before,
uh,
you know,
because I would tell you right now,
dude,
like what's you're getting involved in there?
You know,
if that goes south,
you're going to break two hearts.
Okay.
Cause there's two people that are going to fall in love with you in that thing.
So make sure you're,
you're prepared and you don't waste her time and that poor kid's time.
All right,
so there you go.
That's my advice to you.
This isn't,
you know,
oh,
look at the titch.
I want to fuck her.
This is not that situation,
you know.
Alright.
Advice Dick,
the douchebag friend.
Dear Billy Angel tits.
Um,
I didn't know what that means,
but I,
oh,
anytime anybody calls me an angel,
I take that as a compliment.
Um,
I guess cause there is white as an angels gown,
maybe it's an insult.
I don't know.
Billy red tits,
Billy devil tits.
It can go either way on that.
Um,
love the podcast.
I thank you.
Uh,
essential.
Always offering great wisdom and words to live by.
I'm really not.
I'm a fucking moron and you guys listen to me for some reason.
Maybe you could help me out with this one for the sake of iniquity up.
I said that right.
Let's call this Douche bag friend of mine.
Dick Dick is the kind of person that can get annoying and touchy towards women
when he's drunk,
to the point where it starts to border on harassment.
It's always weird.
It always weirds me the fuck out.
And I don't know how to address this behavior.
Simple be like,
hey dick,
will you fucking knock it off?
What's wrong with you?
Keep your hands to yourself.
He goes,
a few weeks ago,
he met this 18 year old girl at a bar.
What the fuck she doing at a bar,
which we had a great time with.
We all went to Dick's house afterwards for a couple more dicks drink.
Sorry.
In Dick tried to make some moves on this girl.
He couldn't get into her pants that night.
However,
however,
last Friday he did.
Now this is where it gets crazy.
The next day he took the girl to a yearly festival to celebrate Liberation Day
where he and I and a whole bunch of friends at plan to meet up.
This is obviously from another country,
I don't know,
Liberation Day.
She basically only knew me and him.
About 15 minutes into meeting each other there.
The girl started puking up foam.
As it turns out,
she hadn't eaten all day and it popped a pill of ecstasy,
which he had given to her.
Oh my God.
He didn't seem to care what was happening.
So I decided to take her to the bathroom area to clean her up and I brought her
some water and then we went back to look for Dick.
Well,
why would you take her back to him when we finally found and let me guess,
he's trying to hook up with somebody else.
I told Dick like to,
she hasn't eaten all day,
man.
She was puking back there and you should get her son to eat and what did this
motherfucking do?
He quickly walked away and left me to deal with this 18 year old chick for the
rest of the entire day.
We didn't see them again for the rest of the day and we made no effort in trying
to,
he may know effort and trying to find us.
What a Dick being the gentleman that I am,
I decided to stay with to guide her through this ecstasy trip.
Uh,
I gave her some food and tried to have fun and even though we did have fun,
it had already ruined that day for me.
He tried to contact me today,
but I'm really questioning whether he even deserves respond.
What do you think,
Bill?
Should I give this tick another chance or is this the kind of person you want to
cut out of your life?
Complete me.
Thanks.
I'll tell you too.
This is a no brainer.
I pick up the phone and I would just tell him like,
dude,
you are a fucking piece of shit and your behavior around women is completely
unacceptable to the point I would warn other women to stay away from you and I
don't want to be friends with the person like you have a nice life and God bless
the United States of America and that's it.
That's an easy one.
I don't even have to think about that one.
All right.
Fuck banks bail.
I'm writing to you because I believe you were the only man crazy and angry
enough to relate with me on this dude.
Fuck banks.
Fuck them all this month I just found out I owe my bank $45 apparently fitness
connection attempted to withdraw $10 from my account these past two months,
once a month,
and about $5 in my bank two months ago.
This could not cover the $10 fee a month for my gym membership twice,
so now I'm being charged a fee of $40 $5 even though one it's debit to fitness,
didn't actually withdraw the money.
They only attempted to,
nothing went through.
So not only do I owe my bank $45 by also fitness connection about 50 in late
fees and the $2 to $10 fees that never got paid.
Please explain to me why I'm being charged for this transaction that didn't go
through.
Is there a guy working in the dark room at the bank pushing buttons who they
have to pay for the transaction services?
No,
it's all fucking ones and Zeros.
All computers.
Yet another fee that we as consumers except for no reason at all,
even if it makes no sense.
The idea of letting an entity such as a bank holds your money,
seems to carry way more cons than it does parks.
I'm taking your advice and I'm going to call and complain until I get what I
want.
Fuck banks forever.
Now.
All my money lives in the walls.
If the house burns down then so be it.
But at least I didn't get fucked by the man.
Keep the good work and good luck to your Celtics.
Jason Tatum is looking like a baller.
All right.
I agree with a lot of things you're saying there,
but what you didn't take responsibility for,
it was your own actions that led to this.
All right?
If you know that you owe your gym $10 a month,
you're going to have to fucking have that in your bank account.
You didn't have that.
So then,
um,
I don't know how it works.
I know if you write a check and it bounces,
there's a fee.
So you're saying this is debit,
but you're using your debit like paying cash and everything.
So I actually don't think banks are out of line for doing that.
Why would I think is you need to be more responsible with the money.
And like I agree with you.
Banks are fucking evil.
It's a giant Ponzi scheme.
Um,
there's nothing behind the fucking money,
but everybody believes in it.
So,
hey,
we live another day.
All right.
Um,
but the thing about it is,
is you have to learn to make money work for you.
And if you don't understand money,
the wonderful thing about the Internet is if you stop reading people screaming
about politics or watching online porn and all of that Shit,
which I've been guilty of,
all of that stuff,
that's actually a lot of things that you can learn.
And,
um,
what I've learned about money is that money can set you free or it can in
prison.
You,
and it all depends on the choices that you're making and the choices that you're
making.
Sur are horrific and back in the day would have landed you in all of your family
into debtors' prisons.
So you got off easy in the modern world.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I guess taking your money out of the banks,
putting you in your walls.
I,
you know,
I don't disagree with that past a certain amount of fucking money,
but,
uh,
I like to invest in things that are tangible.
I'm into real estate.
I'm into buying apartment buildings and shit like that.
You always have to hedge your bets.
Like I'm buying apartment buildings,
just starting to do that.
And I was like,
I bought a bunch of looking at one,
right?
Because it fascinates me to have income coming into my house every month.
That's not actually in the business that I'm in and the business that I'm in now
considering now with social media,
somebody can just say,
you did something and there's no,
um,
what do you call it?
There's no due process or anything.
And that could literally cause everybody in the business you're in to just walk
away from you and then,
then what do you do?
You know?
So,
uh,
and that's just a new pitfall in this fucked up business that I'm in,
which,
you know,
even before all that,
me too.
Shit.
I mean,
you see these movie stars,
one hit after another,
one after another,
and all of a sudden they have a couple of flops in a row and then they just
disappear.
So this business has always been fickled as hell.
So I planned on doing this anyways.
But after all of that stuff came out in like,
you know,
just recently looking at a Tom Brokaw stuff,
I don't know if he's guilty or innocent,
but the fact that two people can just accuse him
and which is their right.
But the amount of people that just on the accusations now just look at that guy
like he's a complete piece of shit is uh,
isn't right,
isn't,
isn't any more right than if he actually did what they said they were doing.
And then he's actually guilty of it.
But to just,
you know,
an accusation,
it's just an accusation.
But the amount of people that then take that as,
you know,
game set match is,
um,
I mean it's just how the world works.
It's just how it works.
So,
um,
you need to learn about money.
Can't just say fuck banks and then just be antisocial and have your like money
in the walls.
I mean,
you,
you can use banks as long as you know what,
what,
what the game is,
you can use it in your favor.
And um,
and if you just resist
the stupidity of consumption and flat screen TVs and all of this shit that these
stupid fucking celebrities show you when they go into their houses and all,
I had this stupid,
they all,
what they're showing you is a fucking,
the only thing that's impressive as the house,
everything else is a,
is a,
is a liability.
It's all depreciating assets.
They're fucking cars,
all of that shit.
You know what I mean though,
those stupid supercars that that's fucking idiots buy that.
You know,
the only place you really should be taken at as to a track so you can actually
know,
open the thing up.
And then all of those cards,
like,
you know,
you look at those Ford gts I saw when the other day for sale and it was like
fucking 10 15 years old and it was high miles.
It had 6,000 miles on it.
Now it retained most of its value,
but it's just,
I dunno,
I guess unless you're going to buy those things,
but all of those flat screen TVs,
the monogram fucking stupid shit,
the oil painting yourself,
it's just a bunch.
It's a bunch of shit.
It's fucking stupid.
Um,
the pots and pans that you buy that rather than just buying the ones that target
you go out and you gotta go to fucking foofy Foose fucking place and getting by
the,
these Gore may level fucking pots and pans to heat up your fish sticks because
at the end of the day is still that blue collared jerk off.
It's all a fucking waste of money and it's just a bunch of shit.
Now,
if you actually take your money right,
you know,
and,
and learn how to invest it,
and then your money starts making money.
That's when you flip it.
When your money is earning you fucking money.
When you're fucking sitting on a couch watching a game and your money is out
there making you fucking money,
then you understand it.
Um,
and I mean,
I don't even understand it.
Okay.
But I'm just starting to learn how to do it.
And the,
the,
I don't know,
they just,
it's nowhere in the educational system.
You have to seek out that knowledge itself.
Like most quality knowledge that's out there,
you have to seek it out because people aren't going to give it to you.
So that's what I would say.
So I feel few that you're in that position.
I've been in that position,
but,
uh,
I wouldn't say fuck banks use banks rather than have banks use you.
Alright.
There you go.
Was a long explanation,
but an important subject.
All right.
My sister's dead beat boyfriend,
Dear Tara.
Billy.
I mean,
what that means,
I'm a,
I'm a junior in high school and I live with my mother,
sister and a dead bee boyfriend.
Wow.
Uh,
he moved in with intentions to pay rent and help fix up our house.
That is slowly falling apart.
Is this Dwight Yoakam from fucking a sling blade.
But for the past year,
this losers had no job and Pez paid no rent.
Yeah.
He's a gold digging whores.
Uh,
all he does is sleep all day and play Xbox.
He also mentally manipulates my sister by telling her things like her family
doesn't care enough about her to give her a funeral.
Oh my God,
you got to get this guy into the house while he gets high and drunk and touches
guns around.
My mom has on multiple occasions threatened to kick him out because,
but she won't in fear that my sister will go with him.
What in the fuck is
I like,
I don't even understand how a parent loses his level of control in their own
house.
So bill,
what do you think I should do about this situation?
Thank you for being sit down fire.
Thank you.
All right.
I'm looking forward to that family season three a what do you think I should do?
Um,
you got to sit down and talk to your mom
and you just say,
mom,
I know this is a difficult situation,
but you got to kick this guy out of the house.
Um,
he's drunk and he's,
he's,
he's walking around with guns.
You got to choose your family first.
And if our sister chooses him over us,
then so be it.
I mean,
that's it too.
You've got to get that guy out of the fucking house.
Fuck that loser.
That's it.
These are all cut and dried this week,
dumped at fucking Douche than banded that chick after he gave her the ecstasy
learn,
you know,
learn how to fucking use money correctly and get this fucking guy out of the
house.
Jesus Christ.
I feel like I'm cheating on a test here.
These are easy this week.
Sit Down with your mom and just say,
we've got to kick this guy out.
Um,
and this is what I would do.
I would,
um,
if you need to,
I would call the cops before you kick them out.
If you think he's going to be a problem.
I would have the cops come down there and say,
ah,
I don't want this guy in my house anymore.
He does have firearms and I want them out of the house.
Um,
what a fucking loser.
Alright.
Dumped because of infidelity 20 years ago.
A big Billy Ball balls,
massive fan of the podcast and your specials have had me in stitches.
I thank you.
Um,
I really need your advice,
opinions,
opinions slash advice on a situation with recent issues.
I've just broken up with an amazing lady.
The woman I was going to propose to this month,
we had been to get together eight months boat.
When you get to your late thirties,
you can cut through the bullshit pretty quickly and get to a meaningful
relationship.
I knew she was the one I wanted to spend the rest of my life with our
relationship add,
Ben,
Greg,
no arguments,
lots of fun,
laughter and love.
Only one issue existed between us and it seems to have caused the end of the
relationship.
I'm not long after we started dating,
we were out having drinks and we were talking lately about past relationship and
she asked if I'd ever been unfaithful.
I want it to be honest and said yes.
She asked to know more and I just described a time when I was 20 and I had been
an idiot and cheated on my girlfriend at the time.
I stressed that I regretted it and I've never entertained the thought of doing
that again.
I am simply not the same guy.
She reacted fairly badly leaving the pub crying outside before coming back in
and telling me she wished I'd lied.
We managed to get past it though.
That night,
Dude,
you went 20 relationship one on his normal.
We shared many weekends and holidays,
Fun Nights out,
cozy nights in,
talked about a future together and I was invited to share Christmas and New
Year's with your entire family was great.
Even as recently as last week,
she was redesigning my garden for use in the summer.
It is rare.
It's had two more times since then.
Once on my birthday in January when we nearly broke up over it and she was
struggling with it again.
She was so upset,
kept saying,
why couldn't you have just lied?
But we talked through and moved on again or so I thought and then of course
recently when it all ended,
every time it is coming up.
I've been honest and shown true remorse and been very supportive.
Very recently we broke up because she just can't get past my past and said it's
the only thing stopping her from committing to me fully.
She loves me.
Wanted to be talking about having shoulder with me,
blah,
blah.
I don't need to be re this.
Everywhere you look,
all you hear is the once a cheater,
always a cheater lines,
which in my case simply is not true.
I know
that's some of this stems from one of her past relationship,
which in 2016 when she was engaged and the guy broke it off and ran off in front
of her friends.
I don't want to lose this lady.
Only back on Valentine's Day,
she made me present
only back on Valentine's Day.
She made me a president of a hundred reasons why she loves me.
One of them was that she thinks about the future.
She only saw it with me and then I made her feel like no one else has.
This can surely be saved,
but I don't understand it and I don't know what to do.
Thanks bill and go fuck yourself.
Well,
I mean,
what the fuck can you do?
if she's going to judge you by what you did when you were 20 years old,
I just laid on tables that,
listen,
I want to marry you.
All right,
well there's nothing I could do to make,
you know,
I'm paying for the sins of that last guy.
And if you want to throw this relationship because of that away,
because of that last guy that's on you,
dude,
you've done all you can do here,
the tunnel,
all you can do here.
So she's obviously not over that other guy or the pain of that other guy and now
you're paying for it.
Um,
I dunno.
So I mean,
what the fuck can you do?
I would just tell her how I feel about her and just say,
listen,
I'm ready to get married anytime you want to.
But um,
if you don't,
then you got to let me go and I gotta move on.
I got to get,
you know,
cause I'm in my late thirties and if you don't trust me enough that I'm not
going to fuck around on you,
then I,
you know,
I don't want to tell you
that.
I guess it is over,
but it's going to be your call.
It's not my call.
Something like that.
I Dunno.
That's a tough one,
buddy.
All right,
the last one.
Last one here.
Jesus is alone pocket.
It's did I blow my chances with this girl from work?
Hello,
Bill Nye the angry guy.
I'll keep this as short as I can.
Who just opened that door?
Hey Buddy.
Hey,
what's up cutie pie?
Um,
I guess I'm watching you right now.
Hi.
Huh?
What's going on?
Don't pull the cord.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah,
it helped me out with this one.
Oh,
this guy's acids that I blow my chances with this girl from work.
Hello,
Bill Nye the angry guy.
I'll keep this short as I can.
I work with this girl that is a solid 10.
She's absolutely gorgeous and a personality matches mine in 100 different ways
and she's a nerdy chick,
which is a massive plus.
If you saw her,
you'd say,
holy s,
why does she work in a place like this?
Can't curse my kids here a quick and simple.
I got to know her.
We constantly flirted back,
back and forward,
not back and forth near.
They flirted back and forward.
Uh,
she put a lot of attention on me.
Not to sound egotistical,
but I'm a good looking.
I thought he said 62 year old guy's six foot two guy.
My issue is that when I get too comfortable,
I began to spill my red flags and I start to describe my self confidence issues.
I guess I do this to see if she's okay with them.
Bad move.
Yes it is.
After working with her for nearly a year and a half now she seems distant.
Yeah.
You probably waited two.
One.
We used to watch the same shows,
not physically together,
but then come to work the next day and have long conversations about how Austin
though they were.
She used to make efforts to initiate conversation.
Now she barely acknowledges me anymore.
It was really sudden.
Well,
she probably met someone.
I'm not trying to be a dick here.
I've tried,
uh,
a lot to strike up conversation,
but she acts disinterested.
I started trying to make her jealous,
but she doesn't seem to give a f.
Uh,
we work in an almost exclusive male workplace,
so of course everyone is trying to get with her.
It burns my blood to watch it,
but it's my fault.
Is there anything I can do to reserve,
reverse my situation or vice sealed this case shut.
Thanks for reading.
Please come to,
I'm not going to say the city in case she's listening.
Um,
yeah,
I think he blew it with her.
The only girlfriend broke up with you.
Huh?
Your work girlfriend broke up with yeah.
Yeah.
I think what you need to do is move on and,
uh,
stop talking about your confidence issues.
You need to get some confidence in.
You need to get outside the workplace and,
uh,
you need to start hitting on some women and you need to go on dates and then
you're going to feel more confident about yourself and that should the best way
to try and make this woman more interested in you.
All right.
Don't s where you eat anyway,
right.
Don't s where you eat.
Yeah.
Because,
yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Well,
this guy doesn't have confidence,
so he's not going to walk up to a woman that he doesn't really know.
He needs to get over that Hump Hump,
which is why it worked.
Because there's a reason it's supposed to be there.
He feels more comfortable and he,
you know,
she was probably waiting for him to ask around and then he didn't.
And then now it sounds like she's with somebody else.
Yeah.
Or She's just over his,
just over it,
you know,
that'll fun.
Like I said,
work,
boyfriend,
girlfriend relationship,
and now she's moved on.
Yeah,
there you go.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
yeah.
Do plenty of fish in the sea,
you know,
and don't waste your time getting jealous with this person.
Just like you go in there,
you know you don't care.
[inaudible] hi.
Hi.
Oh
yeah.
What's up?
Smiley.
Huh?
Please say hi.
Um,
it was funny now,
and she speaks jibberish but she knows exactly what she's saying and then she'll
just throw in a random real world.
She'd be,
like I said,
Jack Chick kept Gigi Turkey.
Kai.
Yeah.
Huh.
You want to tell some stories?
All right.
That's the podcast for this week a go.
You know what yourselves and I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Bye.
Yeah.
Congratulations to the Tampa Bay lightning.
Give you a bunch of bs.
All right,
I'll talk to you later.